jamais la russie n'acceptera que le
temps soit à ses frontières et
d'ailleurs il faut se souvenir que le
chancelier kohl avait promis à
gorbatchev que lorsque la russie avait
retiré ses soldats l'allemagne de l'est
ce que le temps ne s'étendrait plus
jamais à l'est je crois qu'elle a jamais
eu une volonté sérieuse ni en europe ni
aux états unis de démanteler l'otan
l'idée d'un démantèlement de l'otan
négocier face un pacte de varsovie qui
lui-même n'existait plus
voilà c'était les choses que l'on
pouvait évoquer mais je crois pas que
c'est ça et jamais été sérieux et au
fond finalement à aucun moment je crois
que je crois pas qu'à aucun moment les
occidentaux et fait confiance à la
russie